jay stephen congratulations you're both
in the final round
now we're sending you back to your home
forges where you're nice and comfortable
to make an iconic weapon from history
this by-hander
the zveyhander which means two-hander in
german was a massive sword wielded by
swiss and german mercenary armies in the
16th century sometimes stretching over
six feet in length this by hander was a
long sword featuring an extended grip
and broad guard
as european armies employed more pikes
and pole arms on the battlefield this by
hander emerged as a counter weapon this
enormous sword was used to break up pike
formations by cutting spear ends and
opening up holes in enemy lines due to
its size this by-hander was only wielded
by the biggest and most audacious
soldiers if these soldiers survived
charges into enemy spears they would
often be paid double for their
substantial risk the zveyhander
eventually faded from the battlefield
but survives today in games such as dark
souls
it must be an effective working version
of that weapon
i've never made a zveyhander before of
course i've never made a friction folder
either but that turned out okay right
[Laughter]
your blade must have a double-edged
bland bearish blade
guard ricasso pummel and two lugs
you will have five days at your home
forge to complete this challenge at the
end of those five days you will return
and present your weapons to our panel of
expert judges
only after they submitted them to a
series of brutal tests will they declare
one of you the champion good luck
bladesmiths we'll see you in five days
yeah
today we're gonna forge the damascus and
get our rough forged blank hopefully i'm
looking for about 200 maybe 250 layer
ladder pattern damascus
thing i like to do when i really want to
just kind of get into it and
rock it out i'll eat a super spicy
pepper
[Music]
all right let's go
[Music]
so far it's coming together really good
my grind marks speed up right here in
the center really good
it's time to quench
when you have a five foot blade that
means you have to have almost a five
foot quench tank which means now to get
the blade in the quench tank you're at
ten feet in the air
this could be pretty bad
if the quench doesn't go good we're
gonna have to start all over
we
didn't break
that's what i was hoping for
now i can start working on the guard
[Music]
the scallops look good i got the handle
glued on and tightened down so today
we're gonna get it sharp and test it
i'll see your watermelon and raise your
bucket
[Music]
this bite is a beast
it's gonna be able to take some
punishment
and deal some punishment
[Music]
it will cut
now the survivor was known as a weapon
of intimidation
to test the sharpness of your edge i'm
going to cut into this bundle of sugar
cane twice once with either side
jay you're up first are you ready
ready as i'm ever gonna be
i know my blade's sharp i know it'll do
good i'm expecting something epic but
until it's really put to the test you
just never know
[Applause]
[Music]
it's got a lot of weight to it
but
obviously it's plenty sharp
nicely done thank you all right steven
you're up are you ready can't wait jay's
weapon did really well cutting through
the sugar canes i'm not nervous about
mine but you know i don't know if it's
gonna cut better than his his cut real
strong
[Music]
it's light it's easy to wield
that gourd it's almost where it's
into you when you're swinging it
you can see it cut deep and clean it
looks like the blade held up beautifully
so nice job thank you
bladesmiths the zyhander was a weapon of
war big weapon big damage i will take
your weapon and deliver killing blows on
this ballistic dummy let's see how much
damage your weapon can do
jay you're up first you ready go for it
let's do this
[Music]
it is a heavy weight and it's harder to
manipulate with multiple blows
but on the thrust i was able to go in
one side and all the way
on the opposite side of the dummy
this sir
will kill
thank you
steven you're up next you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
that was brutal
okay steve
the edge of your sword
is sharp enough to lacerate all the way
into the ribs and on the power strike
that would disembowel
and ruin this person
it's the idea
this sword
will kill
good job thank you
gentlemen this is the strength test now
this veyahander was often used against
pike formations so i'm going to take
yours by handers and go against a rack
of pikes here five times with each of
your blades see how far i can break
through
jay you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
wow
when you start swinging this thing it
moves things out of its way
i don't see any damage to your edge
nicely done
thank you
all right steve you're up
do it okay
the third test is probably the one i'm
the most confident about you know i've
i've beat the heck out of this sword and
it's doing well so now it's just how
much mayhem can dave cause
[Music]
obviously it's a good cutter to actually
bend into that wood and split that
right down the middle
very easy to wield because of its light
weight but i think we've
bent just a little bit
it's bent in two directions
and there is a crack now developing in
the handle
gentlemen we've got a lot to discuss
we'll see you back at the forge
i'm concerned i had a warp in my blade
so i don't know who's gonna end up with
the wind
bladesmiths the judges have made their
final decision
it's time to declare one of you the
forged fire champion
[Music]
jay
congratulations
steven unfortunately your sword did not
make the cut dave will explain
stephen i think what you did with your
steel is visually stunning
but what this came down to was the
strength test when we were handled
developed a bend in two directions that
caused a stress fracture in the handle
as well as a slight bend right where the
lugs are and it's those reasons combined
that are sending it home you understand
steven please surrender your weapon
i'm disappointed i really wanted to win
uh but that's okay
i love being at the forge it's hot it's
dirty you'll smell funny but it is so
rewarding
jay congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion good job
thank you
how you feel right now ah i feel like my
heart's about to burst out of my chest
but well it's heaviest weapon i've ever
had to wield in this competition very
well balanced and a powerful weapon too
thank you in the way you built your
handle that tells me a lot about the way
that you make things the wood is fitted
on and then wrapped with leather with
these reinforcing pieces underneath
that's the proper way to construct it oh
thank you well jay
in exchange for that sword and those
socks
and we'll be receiving that check for
ten thousand dollars
when they announced that i was the
winner it felt really good i had people
tell me you know you're good at what you
do but i always have this kind of
self-doubt
to make it all the way to the end and be
the champion i'm so happy
you